support the production of more videos by
visiting the support move section on our
website the link is in the description
below thank you and enjoy so in this
video now that we've talked about atomic
weight I'd like to give a brief
introduction to the mole and molar mass
even though we'll talk more about them a
lot later so what is the mole the mole
is the SI unit for amount and we're
typically talking about some substance
right now one mole specifically is 6.022
14 1 times 10 to the 23rd things it's
just the number right just like one
dozen equals 12 things if you have a
dozen eggs you have 12 eggs if you have
one mole of eggs you have 6.02 to 14 1
times 10 to the 23rd eggs that is an
insane amount of eggs okay so writing it
in scientific notation like this
sometimes scares people it kind of gets
people confused about like that's just
how many is that well if you wrote it
all the way out it would look like this
look like that so about here would be
the millions right billions trillions
and I don't even know what the what it
would be out here but the point is that
it's a gigantic number okay it's
actually Avogadro's number do came up
with it and it's alpha relative numbers
abbreviated as and subscript a but why
is this important why am i bringing it
up now who cares right well one thing is
important because it is the SI unit for
amount so I mean you should we should be
familiar with the SI units and we'll see
it later in when we talk about
stoichiometry it's really really
important later but now I'm bringing up
now because of its relationship to
atomic weight of an element specifically
so one mole of an element can be defined
as the amount of an element whose mass
in grams is equal to the atomic weight
of that element and thus contains
Avogadro's number of atoms this is super
important
super important here I can't make this
cloud as me as I'd like but that's a
very important definition okay and when
you have this mass in grams of one mole
of an element it's called the molar mass
represented by this sort of fancy look
at em here molar mass will talk about
more later again like I said and you can
have the molar mass of compounds in
which case it would just be the sum of
the atomic weights of the elements but
here we're talking about just a
particular element molar mass is
important as a conversion factor between
amount of mass okay so let's think about
this with an example okay if we have one
mole of gold and gold one mole of gold
au is the atomic symbol for gold if we
have one mole of gold that is basically
going to be equal to the atomic weight
of that element right which if you look
on a periodic table for gold it will be
one hundred ninety six point nine seven
grams of gold okay so if you have one
mole of gold you have one hundred ninety
six point nine seven grams gold vice
versa if you have 100 96.7 or 196 point
nine seven grams of gold you have one
mole of gold okay and what you can do
here is if you divide both sides let's
put this in a different color if you
divide both sides by 1 mole of gold what
you have
is that is 106.9 seven grams of gold
over one mole of gold equals one
something equals one it confuses a
conversion factor right this value here
that we've that we basically made this
one hundred ninety six point nine seven
grams of gold per one mole of gold is
the molar mass this is the molar mass of
course the unit's here are grams per
mole grams per mole okay also one mole
of gold is also going to contain 6.022
I've cut off a few sig figs here times
10 to the 23rd atoms of gold or gold
atoms right so you can divide both sides
by one bowl here one mole of gold and
get a conversion factor as well okay so
so we can do that here divided by a 1
mole of gold / 1 mole of gold and then
we have here another conversion factor
if we want to convert between bowls and
number of atoms so this is important as
a conversion factor between amount and
mass so here here we have mass and moles
here we have number of atoms and moles
so we can go from grams to moles to
atoms or backwards right oops so the
point is that it's useful as a
conversion factor okay so let's see this
problem i have here so how many gold
atoms are in a 12.1 gram sample of gold
okay so we'll start off with the grams
so we'll have 12.1 grams of gold we want
to convert this all the way over to
adams first thing we need to get rid of
is the grams right so we'll use the
molar mass 196 point nine seven grams of
gold has is one mole of gold right and
then the grams of gold will cancel now I
have moles right
so if i multiply this all out I would
have moles of gold but I don't want that
i want atoms so i need to cancel these
moles so moles of gold are going on the
bottom well i know that 1 mole has this
many atoms right Avogadro's number of
atoms so that'll cancel moles there and
then i'll have adam choose me gold atoms
so if i multiply all those top numbers
divide all the bottom numbers i'll get
i'll have to have three sig figs
according to what they started me with
I'll have 3.70 times ten to the twenty
second gold atoms and that would be the
answer there so we use both of these
here as conversion factors and getting
this answer okay hope that video was
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
hit it with a like and subscribe for
more content also followed with
University on the different social media
links in the description below thanks
and happy study